There are images of police using violence
against peaceful protesters.
There are images of police creating confrontations,
even attacking but defenseless elderly people.
We played a video of police knocking over
an elderly man with a cane shooting at the
media.
These images have gone viral over the weekend.
Now, I want to be really clear.
I already did a story about how what's going
on in America right now is not just about
one thing.
It's not just about race.
It's not only about police.
It's not exclusively about capitalism or Trump.
This is a massive, multifaceted ordeal.
But that doesn't mean that we shouldn't look
at individual elements.
And one of these elements is the idea of police
as oppressors versus police as victims, as
some have started framing police to be.
We are seeing wholesale pepper spraying of
peaceful protesters.
We've seen members of the media shot with
rubber bullets.
We saw kids hit with pepper spray.
We've seen police ramming police vehicles
into crowds.
A Dallas woman was hit in the face with a
rubber bullet while walking home with her
groceries.
Police wildly hitting people with batons,
in some cases, people walking away from protests.
None of this excuses any violent actions by
protesters.
And there have been horrible actions, including
attacking business owners, beating one business
owner to within an inch of his life or trying
to defend his business, beating a female business
owner brutally out in front of her store.
We have seen it all, but I want to focus in
a little bit here on the police component
and talk about it with you.
There are people and I'm friends with some
of them on Facebook.
I'm seeing it on Twitter.
There are people who have immediately taken
to painting police as victims.
Arguments like a bad cop may have killed George
Floyd in Minnesota, but now innocent police
all over the place are being attacked for
no reason.
And often these arguments end up in debates
about numbers like, well, most police are
good ways at 97 percent or 99 percent.
Well, is it ninety nine or ninety nine point
three percent?
And I said earlier in the show, imagine we
figured out with some precision what portion
of police are the problem is, we might call
it, and what portion of police are not.
Imagine ninety nine point two percent of police
are good.
OK, well, I imagine that most of my audience,
even if you're okay with property crime in
protest where insurance companies are the
ones taking ahead in corporations, I imagine
most of my audience is not OK with unprovoked
attacks against random police officers who
aren't doing anything wrong.
If you do believe that for what happened to
George Floyd in Minnesota, it's OK to just
physically attack an officer in Miami.
We're just not on the same page.
I think that's the minority of my audience.
Does our analysis depend, though, on whether
it's ninety nine point two or ninety nine
point three percent of police that are good
guys in it for the right reasons?
Because what really this is about is context
and power dynamics in total.
Once you concede that most cops are good and
doing their job as best they can, often in
difficult situations, sometimes dangerous
situations.
You also have some cops that go into law enforcement
specifically because they would love an opportunity
to beat the crap out of someone, just like
some portion of people go into the military
because they like the idea of shooting someone
and killing them in some kind of a theater
of war at some point.
That is some percentage.
OK, so.
So then what?
Right.
Whether it's point eight or point seven or
point oh eight percent of police that are
going in because they want to do violence
and misbehave and have all the worst intentions.
What next?
And that's where the more difficult conversations
start.
Questions like are the good cops who are just
doing their job?
Part of the problem in that if you're not
part of the solution, are you implicitly supporting
the status quo of that small percentage of
police that do horrible things and get away
with it?
To what degree should every, quote, good cop
quit in protest to show solidarity with the
protests, leaving our country to be policed
only by the bad cops?
What counts as a sign of being complicit is
silence.
It's a sign of being complicit.
What power and responsibility do individual
police officers have to fix the problem versus
police chiefs versus federal law enforcement
agencies versus versus police unions that
represent officers around the country?
Should the good cops be treated respectfully
or suspiciously absent any reason to believe
they are one of the bad cops?
How should they be treated by protesters?
The average person, etc.?
When you start asking these questions, you
realize that most of the changes that need
to be made are systemic changes.
It needs to be much more likely that if you
do the wrong thing as a police officer, you
will be caught and punished.
It's not likely right now in a lot of our
society, just from this weekend, we have dozens,
if not hundreds of officers on video doing
horrible things.
Are we confident they're going to be identified
and investigated and charged and punished
when it's appropriate?
Not really, because if it were more likely
that they were held accountable, they would
probably change their behavior.
That is a systemic issue.
A good system will take care of that sliver
of police that are doing sick, horrible things.
So let's answer the questions one by one.
First of all, being a police officer is not
like being an accountant.
OK?
Accountants don't represent communities in
the way that police officers do.
Accountants don't wield their power with firearms.
And accountants don't have a power dynamic
relative to their clients, the way police
officers have a power dynamic relative to
the people that they are dealing with.
So on the one hand, the good police officers
must say much more loudly.
These things are not OK and we're committed
to fixing it and changing it and good for
them.
Many police officers have done exactly that.
At the same time, the anger by protesters
towards a system of policing that is fundamentally
broken in many parts of our country is justified
anger.
And this is why it's so powerful when police
officers get it and say, I'm with you, like
the sheriff in Michigan who marched with protesters
in the video going viral.
And it's important for protesters to know
that their anger with the system is justified.
And yet it's not OK to go attack random individual
cops who have not done anything wrong, which
is why it was great to see protesters protecting
a police officer Saturday night who had done
nothing wrong and was separated from his squad.
This is why it was great to see video from,
I believe it was Brooklyn last night with
organizers saying do not interact with the
police.
We are not here for that.
We are here to get our message out.
Do not incite violence.
If you see anyone inciting violence, call
them out.
And, you know, in the midst of this, there's
this really ugly thing that's going on where
there are people sort of making the focus
that the protesters are from out of town.
And at one point, there was some wrong report
that more than half of protesters in some
place were from out of town.
Another report, it said, seems like one out
of seven were from out of town.
Now, sometimes that could mean the next town
over.
It's not really a big deal.
But the point is this out of town narrative
is being used to imply that you merely have
people from other communities who are not
coming in to protest because they actually
are concerned about police brutality and relations
or whatever, but that they are coming into
provoke or to loot or to steal.
You could be concerned about what went on
and drive from another state.
And it also appears to be completely untrue.
So we've got to be really understanding of
how some of these narratives are being used
to distort and discredit real justifiable
anger.
We also have to recognize the growing number
of protests that are saying we are not here
to do violence at all.
And we are not here to do violence to the
police.
But we have to realize that the anger is justified
given the systemic dynamics that exist.
That's sort of my sense of it right now.
I'm glad to hear from you about it as well